I'm here like tripping out I mean I'm
ready for my show to air I want everyone
to see it already tell me about it
it was a lot it's definitely a lot it's
definitely different than the original
very fast there's a lot more of my life
than I that there's a lot more of my
life than I thought would be on the show
on this show I didn't think that I would
really be dating or doing any of that on
the show and you know that's just how it
is when you spend five days a week doing
something some of your real life is
gonna reek it leak out of the show and
this show is just a hundred percent real
I mean I wish they gave us a script like
because the original you know there was
a lot of different you know putting
people in certain situations this was
just like it was hectic its hectic
learning just how to like just talk to
your friend on camera you know instead
of having a script what's the hardest
part about putting yourself out there
you can't take it back you know it's out
there forever every girl you ever go on
a date with every you know word you say
is out there for the rest of your life
and it could haunt you so that's that I
think definitely the hardest part is
just trying to watch what you do and I'm
like a wild dude and I really you know
like sometimes I just like to live my
life free and not really care what
anybody thinks but you know sometimes TV
makes everything pretty serious and I
and I feel like I look back on filming
I'm like I said a couple crazy things
and did a couple of crazy things on the
show that I'm like I don't wish I could
take them back but I'm so nervous for
people to see them just being like oh my
god I can't believe I did that
you know you just did say fun Canadian
TV hello we're Canadians yeah speaking
of being Canadian did your mom give you
any advice it was more just like be
yourself honestly just be yourself and
she does look branding like if you're
just if you just be yourself no one can
hate you for that and I think that's
always a really good piece of advice you
can give to anybody and I feel like
people struggle so much with what their
true identity and it's something I've
embraced since I was a little kid I've
always been like this center of
attention crazy person just lit trying
to live my best life and trying to live
as open as free as possible and so you
know her telling me that really gave me
the boost that I needed to go in and do
this show you feel like people will get
to really know who you are and not sort
of you know I'm Tommy Lee and Pamela
Anderson one son 100% I feel like people
don't really know the real man I feel
like people don't know any sort of me at
all
stayed very quiet in my life and have
been very sheltered from any sort of
public kind of like arena so I think
this is going to be a great opportunity
for people to get to know me
Misha mentioned that being one of the
new cast members was a little bit
difficult because there were a lot of
unresolved issues between the
Cass did you have the same experience I
get roped into everything for some
reason just because I'm like the young
guy and everyone's like Brandon what do
you think I'm like dude I don't know I'm
like not wanna get in the middle of this
you guys have been fighting about the
same for 10 years so I didn't find it
difficult at all really like I got you
know I felt like I was embraced with
open arms and I feel like this is our
weird little twisted family now that's
kind of what I got out of it and I feel
like you know there's definitely it's
crazy that's for sure I definitely
didn't expect to be thrown in like as
much as to the like thrown to the Wolves
as much as I did but I kind of just had
to grab my feet running and you know
kept up a couple of drama I can't
believe I did it I'm over here now I
just want everyone to see it already
like it's Wednesday is it Wednesday
Monday it's Monday today it was
Wednesday today it's Wednesday now right
oh it's Wednesday now I'm like sweating
waiting like another couple of days just
for losing the show what's been your
most memorable experience from the
entire series oh man I don't know I
don't think I can talk about it I want
to spoil anything maybe the best thing
to come out of it you know what's been
missing to come out of it I - I'm super
excited for people to get to know me
that's the best part for me I just want
people to know the real me what my life
is all about and then I'm not just some
you know famous person's kid I've been
here for a while been trying to make my
market and I think this is gonna be an
interesting way for people to get to
know me any plans to head up to Canada
for the summer 100% I'll probably go see
my grandparents on the island Vancouver
Island maybe go visit my old boarding
school shout Shawnigan Lake Wow I can't
believe I just said that that was so
weird
Wow I miss Canada that's for sure I do
alright well have fun in there tonight
sweet you yeah
you